Yo c'est Cyrus et bienvenue dans ce Coup de Phil' #6
qui reprend une forme à peu près normale
et oui je suis de nouveau dans ma chambre
enfin... vous pensez que je suis dans ma chambre...
...parce que vous la voyez...
mais regardez: si je fais ça
*bruit de tissu*
on voit que c'est un fond vert!
Est-ce que je ne serais pas depuis le début
dans un autre endroit...
C'est ce que Descartes se serait demandé
et sa réponse est le Cogito ergo sum :
"Je pense donc je suis"
*musique du générique*
Ça vous est forcément déjà arrivé de faire des rêves
si réels qu'à votre réveil genre pendant quelques secondes,
vous-y croyez encore.
Un peu comme dans Inception,
Le héros ne sait pas s’il est dans une rêve ou dans la réalité, tellement les deux peuvent être semblables.
C’est pour ça qu’il a un objet qui va lui dire s’il est dans l’un ou dans l’autre.
- Dreams, they feel real while we’re in them, right?
It’s only when we wake up that we realize something is actually strange.
- Are we dreaming?
Là, Descartes se dit: «si ça se trouve, je suis actuellement dans un rêve».
En fait, il se dit que ses sens – le goût, le toucher, l’odorat, la vue, l’ouïe – peuvent le tromper.
- Ouais?
- Tu t’appelles Louis?
- Euh ouais!
- Ah je suis désolé, mec, je parlais des sens.
- Ah ok d’accord!
Bref, les sens peuvent nous tromper, comme avec les mirages par exemple.
D’ailleurs, c’est pour ça qu’on ne juge pas un objet qu’avec nos sens.
Prenons un morceau de cire, par exemple – c’est l’exemple de Descartes – le morceau de cire
qui est dur et froid, et que j’approche au fur et à mesure du feu,
et qui devient chaud et mou, c’est le même, pourtant mes sens le perçoivent différemment.
Donc je ne juge pas un objet que par mes sens, parce que mes sens peuvent me tromper.
- Ouais, ouais, on ne va pas me faire croire qu’il y a des objets qu’il n’a pas bien sentis sans se douter
de ce que c’était ! De toute façon, c’est une histoire d’amour… Descartes et les fesses …
Après, que ce soit dans un rêve ou dans la réalité, les sommets d’un triangle sont toujours au nombre de trois,
le rouge est toujours rouge, donc il faut étendre le doute aux idées simples et mathématiques.
Du coup, Descartes va imaginer ce qu’il va appeler un «malin génie» – une force supérieure –
qui va être là pour le tromper, tout le temps.
Donc vu qu’il ne peut pas prouver que le malin génie n’existe pas,
eh bien il va faire comme si le malin génie existait et le trompait tout le temps.
Du coup, Descartes va rentrer dans un doute qu’on appelle «doute méthodique»,
et le mec va douter de tout ! Genre vraiment de tout …
- Bonsoir!
- Bonsoir? Nan mais tu te bases sur quoi pour dire bonsoir? Tu te bases sur le soleil qui n’est plus là
et donc c’est forcément le soir, ou bien ta montre qui pourrait être déréglée ?
Son doute méthodique, il le fait car il veut reconstruire le savoir sur des fondements dont il est absolument sûr.
Il veut trouver une certitude. Puissant le mec! Eh bien, on va faire comme lui!
Imaginez que vous n’avez plus de toucher, de goût, d’odorat, de vue, et même d’ouïe!
Bon, le son, je vais quand même le mettre, sinon on va se faire chier. Eh bien là, qu’est-ce qui nous apparaît?
- Stop! T’es en train de faire quoi, là? T’es en train de penser…
« Oui oui, c’est normal, je pense tout le temps … ».
Non, c’est important! C’est important parce que si tu penses, il y a un sujet à l’action! Ce sujet c’est toi!
Ce que ça implique, c’est que t’existes, mec! Eh ouais, c’est ça la première vérité, mon gars!
Eh ouais, eh ouais … tu la sens la grosse intelligence de Descartes! Tu la sens?
Ah, j’existe, putain!
J’ai douté à un moment! À un moment, j’ai cru que j’existais plus, putain! Heureusement que j’existe…
[D’un chant liturgique] «Je pense donc je suis»
Et le malin génie renforce l’idée de «Cogito». Parce que si le malin génie me trompe,
eh bien cela voudrait dire qu’il faut que j’existe pour qu’il me trompe … eh ouais mon gars!
Dans le «je pense donc je suis», attention au «donc»: ça a été compris comme une déduction,
mais en fait c’est plus une intuition. Du coup, après l’avoir sorti à la base en 1637
dans Le Discours de la méthode, il le ressort plus tard, mais en disant «ego cogito, ergo sum»,
ce qui veut dire «je pense, j’existe», pour mieux marquer le ton de l’intuition. Eh oui, je parle latin, ouais…
D’ailleurs ce mec ne faisait pas que de la philo. C’était aussi une grosse brute en maths, en physique;
tellement une brute que maintenant sa ville de naissance s’appelle Descartes!
Ça s’appelait La Haye, ça s’appelle Descartes…
Donc Jean Jaurès avec ses petites rues à droite à gauche : nul !
En tout cas, j’espère que le Cogito de Descartes est maintenant plus clair pour vous,
rendez-vous sur la page Facebook, sur le twitter;
abonnez-vous pour ne louper aucun épisode du Coup de Phil’,
et moi je vous dis: «Yallah!»
*musique de fin*